bouder allez c'est parti une présence
auprès je vais présenter tout le monde
s'inquiétait pas ya un très gros casting
ce soir manille comment ces blagues vous
dirais que ces prix la date de
présentation s'est passé bouder est en
train de vaud des merguez je connais
hyper bien ouais ben allel en train de
gagner la guerre patrick bruel qui vient
voir au bout d air congo du mali de
faire ma tribune non un jour mais du
bout des césariennes qu'il faut pas
couper les blagues ci ne représentant
pas d'accord bon bah c'est bon voilà
alors boudé à l'entraînement des merguez
zelaya patrick bruel qui vient voir et
tu dois vous dire comment tu vas tu dis
ça va bien et pas très comment tu veux
être le confinement n'a pas beaucoup
travaillé et nous et je sais la vie dure
et toi bouder des bobos je vois bien les
merguez ans que c'est sont bonnes et
patrick bruel en fait il voulait une
merguez tu vois il voulait un sandwich
mais n'avait pas d'oser sur lui et 10
bouder s'te plaît ça ne dérange pas de
me faire un sandwich merguez et je te
paie plus tard tu me fais un crédit la
bouder regarde patrick hude écoute tu as
vu la banque cic là bas le 10 juin me
dis-je un pacte avec eux rivaux pas de
merguez et moi je fais pas de crédit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce soit il a promis de nous régaler à
côté monsieur aziz saisie
ça fait longtemps qu'on l'attend si la
solution
depuis tout à l'heure il ya le
producteur d'émissions qui me dit c'est
le loup apelle le monsieur à 10 mai
qu'il est bête alors 6 petit bac de
présentation c'est votre première
histoire
ah bah alors moi je choisis une courte
mais efficace et comme je l'adoré bouder
la wii wii d'insulter les maires dont
vous connaissez mes goûts à l'émir côté
de lui se voir ça je sers exactement
c'est bien entouré alors oui c'est vrai
au bout du bout des boudins et batteries
il est de plus en plus beaux albums
il a raison je pars de loin alors là
vous êtes arrivé loin surtout d'asie
alors c'est un petit garçon qui va voir
sa mairie qui dit ma main je comprends
pas papa les noirs toi tu as la peau
blanche
moi je suis chinois sa mère ne me prends
pas la tête avec ça si tu savais ce qui
s'est passé ce soir là soit content de
ne pas aboyer
[Applaudissements]
quel bonheur bonsoir c'est une petite de
présentation ou alors c'est un mec
heures
je la leur mort il entre dans le bus
vous avez besoin de jouer car je veux le
faire mais plus cher doutez-vous trouver
d'horus n'ira dire toulon dans le bus il
y voir derrière vous êtes tous des penne
sur les côtés tous des cocus et devant
tous des connards là le chauffeur il met
un coup de frein et tout le monde
s'éclate dans le bus
his rêve il attrape le bourg et ils lui
dirent répète un peu ce que tu as dit
toi c'est qu'ils les connards les
costumes et les [ __ ] mais bourré dit
j'ai pensé maintenant raconte usa tous
mélangés
[Applaudissements]